Two things: taking the necessary steps and placing one's trust in God.
Trust in
God, the Exalted, the
Almighty.
[Music]
God, the Exalted.
Imam Ahmad, may God have mercy on him, was asked about a man who sat in
the mosque and said, "I don't do anything; my sustenance comes to me."
Imam Ahmad, may God have mercy on him,
said, "This man is ignorant."
He mentioned the hadith of the
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, that God has placed
his sustenance under the shade of a spear. It is necessary to take the necessary steps.
The Companions used to trade and work in
their date palm groves. How strong was their trust in God, the Exalted!
He mentioned the hadith of Ibn Abbas that the Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him,
said, "Seven thousand of my nation will enter Paradise
without reckoning.
They are those who do not seek omens, do not believe in omens, and rely on their Lord."
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him, narrated the hadith of
Ibn Abbas, may
God be pleased with them both, peace and blessings be upon him, about
7000. The
meaning of "do not seek ruqyah" is that
they do not ask others to perform ruqyah for them, saying, "So-and-so, perform ruqyah for me!" Rather, they
rely on God and perform ruqyah for
themselves. "Do not believe in omens" means they do not take omens. "Do
not see omens"
means
that if they see something unpleasant, like a
cat or a dog, they will not seek ruqyah for them.  For example, he left his
work or going out for this purpose, and
all of this is united by reliance on God Almighty.
This is from the grace of God Almighty, that
there are 70,000 who will enter Paradise as soon as the
judgment begins among the people. They will enter Paradise without
reckoning or
punishment.
[Music] May
God include us, you, our parents, and our sheikhs among them. Rather, it is
from the grace of God Almighty that
when the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, asked God for intercession for his nation,
God said to him, “You will have 70,000 who will enter Paradise without reckoning
or punishment.” God
Almighty, peace and blessings be upon him,
God Almighty,
God Almighty.
From the mercy of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, for his nation, he said, “
O my Lord, increase it for me.” So
God Almighty said, “Then you will have this,” and he gestured with his
right and left hands and
in front of him, meaning He increased them by multiple numbers, not
only 70,000, but more than that.
God Almighty, peace and blessings be upon him. Rather, it was mentioned
in another hadith in Musnad Ahmad,
authenticated by Al-Albani,
when he mentioned 7,000, he said, “And
you will have with every
70,000.”
Ahmad  May God Almighty have mercy on him.
[Music]
[Music] He
said: Chapter on what is disliked of idle talk. Imam Bukhari,
may God have mercy on him,
mentioned the hadith of Al-
Mughirah, that he
heard the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him,
say upon finishing the prayer: Al-Mughirah, Mu'awiyah, Al-Mughirah,
God, peace and blessings be upon him, said: There is no god but God alone, He has no partner. To Him belongs dominion and praise, and He is over all things competent. He repeated this
three times: There is no god
but God alone, He has no partner. To Him belongs dominion and
praise, and He is over all things competent. He used to forbid idle talk, so she said, it was said, it was said.
The meaning of this is the prohibition of
excessive, useless talk.
The prohibition is greater if it is idle talk that falls under
backbiting, slander, or inciting discord.
[Music] And
excessive questioning, meaning persistence in asking and questioning
about what is useless
or does not benefit the questioner. That is, excessive questioning is more
than questions that have no meaning
or benefit. Peace and blessings be upon him.
[Music] And it
was said: Asking for money and seeking it,
meaning wasting money and asking people for money excessively.
[Music]
Therefore, he said after that: wasting money. Peace and blessings be upon him, and
preventing, and its meaning is the
prohibition of preventing what has been commanded.  By giving
and asking for what he does not deserve, if he is
commanded to give something like charity and zakat, he
withholds it.
But if the need arises and he is not among those who need it, he
asks for a
hadith and withholds it. The practice of burying daughters alive is what the people of pre-
Islamic times used to do. If a
daughter was born to him, he would be ashamed and embarrassed before people, and the situation would force him
to kill and bury her.
Yes, this is burying daughters alive. It also falls under the category of disobedience to
parents, which is forbidden. This is one of the major
sins. May God’s prayers and peace be upon him. He
said, “Chapter on guarding the tongue,” and the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said, “
Whoever believes in God and the Last Day should speak
good or remain silent.” God Almighty says, “Not a
word does he utter except that there is a watcher by him ready (to record it).” The Imam, may
God have mercy on him, said, “
This is an explanation of guarding the tongue from uttering
what is not permissible according to Islamic law or what is unnecessary in
speech, for most of the sins of the children of Adam come from
the tongue.”
Sheikh, may God Almighty love him, said, “And he
explained that one of the characteristics of the people of faith is
either to speak good or to remain silent.
This is a principle that is
very useful in staying away
from trials and problems, even within the Salafi ranks and
even among students of knowledge. Speak good and remain silent. Do not be a
cause of…”  In times of strife and division, there is a
blessing
[music]
[music] that
preceded and
mentioned the verse in which there is an explanation that the recording angels
write down everything, and that among their attributes is that
they are guardians and present.
This is the watchful guardian, and
the watchful one is the present one. These are descriptions of these
recording angels, and not as some people think, that they are names of
angels.
[music]
are
present. And
he mentioned in it the hadith of Sahl ibn Sa’d
that the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, said: “Who will guarantee
me?”
Here, meaning fulfillment, guarantees me. Whoever fulfills by refraining from sin, may God bless him and grant him peace, is
in front of Bukhari, may God have mercy on him. Sahl
ibn Sa’d, may
God bless him and grant him
peace. [music] The guarantee here is for what is between his jaws, which is his tongue, and what is between his legs, which is his private parts. So whoever guards his tongue and private parts from sins, he said: “I guarantee him Paradise, may
God bless him and grant him peace.” [
music]
In it is an explanation that most of the afflictions that come to a servant come
from the direction of the tongue and the private parts. [
music] And
he mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurairah, he said: “Whoever believes in
God and the Last Day should speak good or remain silent.” And
this has passed with us.
Bukhari, may God have mercy on him.
Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him.  On his authority, may
God bless him and grant him peace, and
whoever believes in God and the Last Day should not harm
his neighbor. This contains an encouragement to be kind to one's neighbor and to prevent
harming him. We do this, may God bless him and grant him peace.
[Music]
Then he also explained
the virtue of honoring
the guest. He said, “Whoever believes in God and the
Last Day should honor his guest.” May
God bless him and grant him peace. In the
hadith that follows,
on the authority of Abu Shurayh al-Khasa’i, he said, “My ears heard and my
heart understood that the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, said, ‘Hospitality is for
three days.
What is its reward?’”  He said, "One day and one night,"
that Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him, narrated
the hadith of Abu Shurayh al-Khuza'i, may
God bless him and grant him peace. It is
stated in one version
that he said, "One day and one night, and
hospitality is for three days.
Whatever is beyond that, meaning more than three days,
is charity given to him."
[Music]
Ibn al-Qayyim mentioned that a guest has a right over the one he stays with, and that it is three
times.
Ibn, may God have mercy on him,
[Music] the
first is an obligatory right, and this is one day and one night; the
second is
complete and recommended, and this is three days
according to the custom; the
third is charity, which is what exceeds
three days.
[Music]
Then it is completed in the hadith: "Whoever believes in God and the Last Day should
honor his guest. Whoever believes in God and the
Last Day should speak good or remain silent." This is once a
hadith of God Almighty. He
mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurayrah, that he heard the Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace,
say, "A person may utter
a word without realizing its meaning, meaning he does
not seek the meaning of this word nor reflect on what
he said, and because of it he will
fall into Hellfire farther than the distance between the East and the West."
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him,
Abu Hurayrah, may God be pleased with him, may
God bless him and grant him peace, may God bless him and grant him peace.
This contains an encouragement to guard the tongue, and that a person
should,
before speaking, reflect on what he says.  He speaks if he sees
benefit and good in it, and if
he sees no benefit or good in it, he remains silent. The
Sheikh, may God preserve him,
before
mentioning the hadith of Abu Hurairah
that the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said: “A servant may
utter a word pleasing to God, and
God will raise him in rank because of it. But a servant may utter
a word displeasing to God, and God will leave no door open for it, and it will
plunge him into Hell.” Imam Bukhari, may
God have mercy on him, narrated the hadith of Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him.
God, peace and blessings be upon him.
[Music]
Hasten
God.
This shows the seriousness of words, and
that one may say a word
thinking it is worthless in God’s sight, but it raises one’s
rank with Him. A person may be guided and enter Islam because of a word, and an innovator may
abandon his innovation because of a word.
Thus, do not belittle any
word you say for good.
[Music]
Spean [
Music]
Explain
[Music]
and perseverance
due to a statement, so do not stop speaking
encouragingly.
Likewise, on the contrary, one may say a single word that plunges
him into Hellfire, and he will not consider its consequences. It contains
God’s wrath, mockery of the Sharia, and ridicule.
By religion
[music]
statement ang God Almighty and
God Almighty
said: Chapter on weeping out of fear of God.
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him,
mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurairah about the seven whom
God will shade in His shade, and a man who remembered God and
his eyes overflowed with tears. The
hadith of Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with
him.
God, may God’s prayers and peace be upon him.
God Almighty
[music]
This contains an explanation of the virtue of weeping out of fear of God Almighty, and that it is one of the
reasons for obtaining shade on the
Day of Resurrection.
It came from the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, who said: A
man who wept out of fear of God, peace and blessings be upon him, will not enter Paradise.
God Almighty mentioned weeping in His Book many times. God Almighty said: “And they fall down upon their faces weeping, and it increases them in humility.” And among the things that
help a servant to weep out of fear of God Almighty are
a number of reasons:
First, feeling fear of God Almighty.
Second, reflecting on the Quran.
Third,
knowing the great reward of weeping out of fear of God.
Fourth, reflecting on your condition and the condition of sin and transgression.  The
fifth is feeling remorse
and a sense of negligence, the
sixth is remembering a bad end, and the
seventh is
listening to
moving words and impactful sermons and reading
books on this subject, especially books of the Sunnis. Among the
greatest things that induce tears is
mentioning the chapter that follows, which is the chapter on fear of
God.
[Music] Glory be to God, the Most High. And
mention the hadith of Hudhayfah
on the authority of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, who said: There was a man among those who came
before you who had a bad opinion of his deeds. He said to
his family, "When I die, take me and throw me into the
sea on a stormy day." So they did so to
him. Then God gathered him and said, "What made you do what you did?" He said, "Nothing made me do it except fear of You." So He forgave him. Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him, said: Hudhayfah, may God bless him and grant him peace, was a man among the people who said to his family, "When I die, take me and throw me into the sea on a stormy day." So they did so to him. Then
God gathered him and said, "What made you do this ...  The stations of
servitude and the requirements of faith in
God Almighty
[music] as in His
saying, "And fear Me, if you are believers." Only those
of His servants who possess knowledge truly fear God
Almighty.
God, the Exalted, the Majestic, the Sublime, the Sublime, the Sublime, and
the servant fears the
evil consequences of his actions, the evil end of his life, and the
evil of his deeds
[music]. He
also fears being immersed in sins and
not turning away from them.
This man, due to his poor opinion of his actions and his fear of
God, did this. This may have been
permissible in the past
[music].
This is evidence of the greatness of God Almighty, the Sublime, the Exalted.
Then he mentioned the hadith of Abu Sa'id al-Khudri, that the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him,
mentioned a man in what had passed or
before him.
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him,
Abu Sa'id, may God be pleased with him, may God bless him and grant him peace
[music].
This is like what was mentioned previously in the hadith.
He said, "Chapter on refraining from sins," meaning abandoning them and turning away from them
after repenting. On
that, Imam Bukhari, may
God have mercy on him, the Exalted, the
Majestic,
mentioned the hadith of Abu Musa,
that the Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him, said, "My example and the example of what
God sent me with is like that of a man who
came to a people and said, 'I saw the army.'"  With my own eyes,
and I am the naked warner,
so flee, flee! A group obeyed him and set out at
their leisure and were saved. Another group disbelieved him, so the
army attacked them at dawn and overwhelmed them.
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him,
Moses, may
God bless him and grant him peace, and then
[music]
eyesem
nak
save
[music]
out slowly ste and another group did.
This contains an explanation of
the parable given by the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace,
on one who is responsible for
himself,
because he warned his nation. Whoever obeyed him was saved, and
whoever did not obey him perished. The
hadith
exleat
[music]
to his people and warned them that the army would attack them at dawn. So a
group set out, meaning they traveled at the beginning of the night and fled and were saved. A group remained, so the
army attacked them at dawn. So
[music]
He mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurairah
that the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, said: My
example and the example of the people is like that of a man who kindled a fire, intending
good with this fire.
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him,
Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him, may God bless him and grant him peace, the blessings of God Almighty.
When this fire became lit,
moths and animals began to fall into the fire, and he tried to pull them out, but they overwhelmed him and plunged in.
He pushes them into it because he pushes them, like a moth trying to escape
the fire, and they rush into it and push him, and they
rush in. This is the proverb: in the many, he pushes them and enters into the fire, however, they keep overpowering him, and
he tried to stop.
Then he explained this proverb, saying: I will hold you back from the fire. The hold is tied with the waistcloth. He wears the waistcloth tied with it, as if he is
taking it and pulling it, dragging it, in order to save him
from this fire. But they do not obey, and whoever does not obey will
fall into this fire. May
God’s peace and blessings be upon him.
[Music] May
God bless him and grant him peace.
Then he mentioned the hadith of Abdullah bin Amr, may God be pleased with
them both,
that the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, said: “A Muslim is one
from whose tongue and hand other Muslims are safe, and a true emigrant is one who abandons
what God has forbidden.”
Imam Bukhari,
may God have mercy on him,
Abdullah bin Amr, may God be pleased with them both, may
God bless him and grant him peace. This is one of the comprehensive sayings of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him. May God bless him and grant him peace. A
true Muslim is one from whose tongue
people are safe from sinful speech, and
from whose hand people are safe from harming anyone.
He mentioned that one type of emigration is to abandon sins and
adhere to acts of obedience.
[Music] The
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, mentioned this to comfort those
Muslims who did not emigrate after the conquest of
Mecca, because emigration had ceased. The
intended meaning is the emigration of the people of Mecca to Medina, which ceased.
Otherwise, the obligation of emigration
remains until the Day of Judgment.
Chapter: The Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said: “If
you knew what I know, you would laugh little and weep
much.” Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him, may God bless him and grant him peace.
[Music]
The intended meaning of knowledge here is knowledge of God’s greatness and His vengeance against those who…
Knowledge of
the horrors of the Day of Resurrection,
knowledge
of what happens in the grave—this is the knowledge that brings
tears out of fear of God. May God
protect us.
[Music]
This is like what Al-Hasan, may
God have mercy on him, said: He used to say, "Whoever knows that death is his
destination," meaning that it will inevitably happen to him. Al-Hasan said, "And the Resurrection is his appointed time,"
[Music] and
standing before his appointed time. He hastened, so it is his
right to prolong his sorrow in this world, meaning to
increase his fear of God, the Exalted.
God, the Exalted, and he mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him: The
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, used to
say, "If you knew what I know, you would laugh little and
weep much." And likewise, the
hadith of Anas is similar: "If you knew what I know,
you would laugh little and weep much." Like the chapter
in front of Bukhari, may God have mercy on him,
Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him, and
Anas, may God be pleased with him,
said, "Chapter: Hell is veiled by desires,"
meaning that it is covered
by them, so desires are a
cause of falling into Hell.
He mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurairah.  May God be pleased with him, the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him,
said: “Hell is veiled by desires, and
Paradise is veiled by noble deeds.” May God have mercy on him. He, may God be pleased with him, said
in another narration: “It is veiled, surrounded, and placed around it.” [
Music]
[Music]
This contains a condemnation of desires,
even if the soul inclines towards them, and an encouragement to acts of obedience, even if
the soul dislikes them. It also indicates
that salvation
from Hell requires striving against the self,
which means distancing oneself from what the soul loves and embracing what is
difficult for the soul. [And
striving
against the self] Our
Prophet Muhammad, God willing,
will suffice with this. May God’s prayers,
peace, and blessings be upon our Prophet Muhammad.